Our teachers taught us many things, sometimes without us even realizing it,...
...like when they sent us to the corner.
We only saw it as a punishment...
...but we actually learned many things there.
We didn't learn the capitals of Europe...
...but we learned that if something isn't ours, it belongs to someone else.
We didn't learn to speak languages in that corner...
...but we learned the importance of listening in any language.
Teachers send children there to come back as people.
And so teachers, we want to thank you.
And we also want you to know that we still go to that corner.
In fact, now we love to go.
Although it's true that the corner isn't the same anymore,...
...and sometimes it doesn't even look like a corner, we each have our own.
And every time we need to think, gather strength or make an important decision,...
...we send ourselves to our special corner.